I'm like I think they just
tell us this to like make us delusional
for a lifetime and I started thinking
about our smartness and I'm like are
women I like to think I'm a smart chick
but we can all be idiots so it's like
let me think about this
if we're so smart where is
the female Elon Musk where is the female
Bill Gates where is the female even I
was thinking of the influencers I'm like
influencing and like monetizing beauty
is something women are better at
um just because we're hotties but I'm
like is there a female Ben Shapiro
that's like equally as smart as him or
smarter no
no I've never seen a chick that recites
stats like Ben Shapiro